how amazing does she look tonight i know
everyone was like oh the chemistry's
it's like how could it not be there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she walked out and i was like i might
have to try to steal her from brian
austin green sharna is looking so
gorgeous oh my god if there was anyone
who would be here thank you
well we finally know the truth that you
two are dancing together
um you told me in advance you said
you're so excited for this that it's
gonna be something where you get to
learn about what your partner is
passionate about what have those first
rehearsals been like we saw a cute
little package maybe maybe a little
tension
what if he can't move his hips and i'm
like oh i'm sorry did you hear something
from this area over here because i it's
i heard something well but who knows man
what if he's really awkward what if he's
really awkward stop freeze don't move if
i mess this up i wouldn't be surprised
if sharna left me no it's not real
you know we we're with that couple that
just takes that can i say that we just
take the mickey out of each other you
know what i mean yes we love to have fun
with each other mickey good choice of
words what do you want to say the other
one because yeah i know i get it i
understand you know what i mean i mean i
said it live but whatever you did oh you
didn't you said you didn't want to get
it right i right so it's teasing we do
we playfully
this is what we do well and then we saw
your chemistry
live on camera i got to tell you you
guys i was thinking thank you for
bringing sexy back to dancing with the
stars it's been a minute how could he
not though look at him
we saw a kiss we saw the connection i
think this is a really cool opportunity
i mean we talked about this before to
to have a real relationship and to have
that chemistry that's not you're not
trying to create it for the show it's
there so then it's like you're creating
around it and it's a different thing to
show people i think than what they've
seen on the show for a while are any of
the other partners jealous of your
partnership yeah
sure yeah maybe but in all honesty these
guys have been here for so long and all
of the other pros are just so happy for
me
i think i see yeah but they're still
giving us a hard time are they i haven't
noticed that okay well okay
brian i'm quoting you from the episode
you said if i messed this up wouldn't be
surprised if she left me right what are
the risks really what's at risk here if
this goes wrong this competition
well okay so here's the risk
when we when we started dating she
always said that one of her dreams with
me was hey we'll dance together one day
right
super sweet romantic totally didn't mean
on the show right and then and then the
concept of like if i suck at this she's
gonna have to write off that dream and
be like oh so we'll get into skydiving
like that's that's the next stream you
know
yeah like you know base jumping that'll
be our thing okay so i didn't want to i
didn't want her to have to write that
dream off because i was terrible at it
so oh
one down well we we got we all hoped for
a steamy kiss on tv oh you did how did
it feel
i felt natural and easy honestly like
bright came out and performed the heck
out of it was the best that he's danced
he has so much potential
and i was just so proud of him you know
what i'm like so proud and then i
couldn't not kiss him at the end of it
and then i was giddy at the end of that
i was like whatever happens i'm good
don't get salty
no no no no i said you know i want one
more kiss right now
maybe just a little peck on the cheek i
don't know you're gonna have to watch
you're gonna have to repeat the episode
yeah
yeah we only do one show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]